to the members of the Security Council I
must say enough is enough we have taken
an incremental approach and despite the
best of intentions it has not worked
members of this council will no doubt
urge negotiations and a return to talks
but as I have just outlined we have
engaged in numerous direct and
multilateral talks with the North Korean
regime and time after time they have not
worked the time for half-measures in the
Security Council is over the time has
come to exhaust all of our diplomatic
means before it's too late we must now
adopt the strongest possible measures
Kim Jong Un's action cannot be seen as
defensive he wants to be acknowledged as
a nuclear power but being a nuclear
power is not about using those terrible
weapons to threaten others nuclear
powers understand their responsibilities
Kim jong-un shows no such understanding
his abusive use of missiles and his
nuclear threats show that he is begging
for war war is never something the
United States wants we don't want it now
but our country's patience is not
unlimited